oh my god i think i broke the chair
i accidentally found the most
mind-blowing end game theory on the
japanese internet
also you guys forced me to sing being
sake on camera to celebrate
100 000 subscribers
all of this and more upcoming in this
video
okay let's do this
what's up everybody ohara here and today
is a good day because today i have not
just one
but two real goodies for you and i
personally definitely know
which one i'm more excited about
nope not that part you'll get to witness
me questioning my life choices in real
time if you make it till the end of this
video
the bad news for me is you will
kiss it's a damn [ __ ] good video now
i'll summarize how we got here as
quickly as possible
so we can get to the juicy bits let's
put 30 seconds on the clock
we reached 100 000 subscribers still
can't believe that that happened
i asked you guys to come up with a video
idea to celebrate
you guys picked singing being sake over
eating bread
why then i thought to myself instead of
torturing you guys
right from the start why not talk a
little bit about the song itself for a
bit
i think there might be a thing or two in
there that might be interesting
so i looked it up
and what i stumbled upon blew my goddamn
mind
was that 30 seconds damn it
don't forget to subscribe okay let's cut
to the chase
the premise of this theory is from a
japanese one piece fan
who goes by the name of typical mixed in
with my own ideas and
other random stuff i found on the
interwebs that guy
or girl went through the original
japanese lyrics of the song and gave his
interpretation for each important line
now without giving too much of the mind
bow that i definitely had away
the basic idea is that this song talks
about the final island of the grand line
love tale if that's just too far fetched
i'm gonna go watch something else
wait before you click away already let
me also spoil the last line of the song
in the english translation it goes never
ending ever wondering how funny
travelling tale
that already sounds a little bit like
love tale but in the japanese original
it's actually way more in your face the
word that oda uses
waraibanashi literally means a love
tale literally like that's so
straightforward that it
actually makes me wonder whether oda
just put that into 2003 google translate
and then got love tale as a result and
just you know went with it
seems about right after all oda put a
ridiculous amount of thought into this
and had the song already done
many many years before we actually
reached the bark while the island itself
is first mentioned as far back as
chapter 105
i hope that this convinces you that this
song is not only a good chance to
humiliate a poor youtuber
but also carries a deeper meaning
hinting at the climax of the story
okay let's start with the very first
line of the song let's go and deliver
being sake
this already brings up two important
questions
who the is binks and what is his sake
well according to chipiko as the song is
pretty old
bings is probably someone who's already
dead top candidates is whoever wrote
that song so
joyboy the d-clan the kozuki or
all of them and sinsake has a pretty
strong symbolism in japan
and is often associated with one's life
story being sake might actually be
delivering his story now this story saw
the theory
is the true story of the world which is
engraved in the glyphs there are four
road poneglyphs leading to lovetale but
more interestingly there are nine
historical ones that contain the lost
history
according to this delivering bing sake
then means nothing but finding
all nine historical pony glyphs
stringing them together
and bringing the full story with you to
love tale
and speaking of robin when brooke plays
the song for the first time for the
straw hats
robin mentions that she has heard it
somewhere before
on a pirate ship she traveled on maybe
only the word she uses in japanese is
natsukashi
an adjective that can't really be
translated literally but expresses font
memories of a time long past
now i think the only time robin has
genuinely warm memories of
is her time with the scholars and if she
heard the song in connection with the
research of the pony glyphs and the
ancient kingdom
wouldn't that make perfect sense
[Music]
now the second interesting part of the
first verse is this
the birds sing as they draw circles in
the sky circles
birds yup
this might very well be a reference to
the kozuki themselves
the creators of the poneglyphs the bird
in front of a circle that might very
well depict the sun
as well as four arms that remind us of
the classical jolly roger
keep that in mind we'll get back to that
in a second
now the last interesting line from the
first verse is this
tsumugino satoyo sumagino sato is the
village of
spinning the village were what exactly
was spun
well why not the story that is engraved
in the pony glyphs
this would mean that the village talked
about in this old song
would be no other place than wano itself
where we are right now the place where
the pony glyphs were crafted
all the way back during the white
century are you warmed up already
good then let's go to verse two cause
we're just getting started
[Music]
after introducing bings the kozuki and
their story in the first verse
the second one seems to describe some of
the history we just talked about
we start with this
this is translated as we are pirates
sailing through the sea
this however is too liberal waterku
doesn't mean sail but means to cut or to
divide
thus the line actually says we are
pirates parting the sea
now yes this could of course just mean
cutting through the waves with the ship
but what if this was actually way more
literal remember the kozuki crests
well what if the pirates did indeed cut
the sea
let's say in four parts using a giant
continent
and a dangerous current and could the x
be the literal location of love tale
the backside of reverse mountain that
technically
is the end of the grand line now the
song continues with this
now comes a storm through the far-off
sky it seems that this seems to be a
reference to
war the storm brewing being a metaphor
for conflict
thus this line might tell us about a war
in the past or
in the future related to the islands
[Music]
the verse then ends with if you lose
your nerves
this breath could be a last but if you
just hold on
the morning sun will rise this seems to
refer to the dangers associated with
love tale
it tells us that people have failed
before
and died trying but even though people
failed the morning sun will rise
the morning sun in other words
the dawn thus the person who will bring
the dawn will one day appear
after many others have failed this my
dear viewers is nothing else
but inherited will
[Music]
and speaking of leading themes in the
story the third verse starts talking
about the dreams of today and tomorrow
once again this
is inherited will and passing on dreams
to another
in this case it specifically means the
dream of those who originally wrote that
song
it continues
once again i think that the english
translation kind of misses out here
the line literally translates not to
waving out goodbyes we'll never meet
again
but to this even though i will never
meet the waving shadow
this seems to refer to someone living in
the present only the living can cast
shadows and so it directly addresses the
one who has inherited their dream
in that moment in time but don't look so
down for tomorrow night the moon will
also rise
the moon i actually made an entire video
about its meaning and its connection to
the past
some time ago so if you're interested in
that
i'll link that video for you up here
apart from its
heavy symbolism what it actually reminds
me of
is your name in case you haven't seen
the movie
watch it it's absolutely fantastic
but if you don't want to get spoiled
skip like 20 seconds ahead here for a
moment
in the story at dusk when the moon comes
up it's possible for two worlds to touch
so that might already be a hint that
love tale
is only accessible during a certain time
period at dusk and again
at dawn now the song ends with this
doesn't matter who you
are someday you'll just be bones never
ending
ever wondering how funny travelling tale
now what this line
obviously says is that everyone will
have to die someday
and then the song ends by literally
name-dropping loftail
the never-ending ever-wandering islands
so what's the big payoff of this video
here
hold tight love tale is the island of
the dead
this is where people go in one piece how
do we know
brooke thanks to his fruit he was able
to return from the land of the dead
he's the one that first plays the song
the first crew member that luffy wants
is
a musician brook introduces us to the
concept of souls and soul power
his clash with big mom is all about the
soul
but wait there's more remember rayleigh
saying that they were
too early when they reached love tale
well the simple answer to this might be
they
weren't dead yet raja also told his
first mate that he would never really
die
and gladly handed himself in to be
executed
the d don't fear death and greeted with
a smile
they are somehow connected to the land
of the dead and
is it really a coincidence that they
were singing the song on roger's ship
when they traveled to love tale in
chapter 967
and i also want you to take a look at
this panel here of yasuya at his
execution
the last thing he says is this i will
now make my way to the other world
let's sing all together why would you
sing when you're about to die was yasuya
about to sing being sake
in other words is it possible that love
tale
is actually so difficult to reach
because it means
that's what it means because it means
entering the realm of the dead
an island that only appears at dusk and
that you only have one chance of
entering and one chance of leaving
as a living person this exact concept is
actually quite popular in pirate law
it's called
davey jones's locker the place where the
souls of sailors go after they die a
concept for example
also used in the third pirates of the
caribbean movie are the straw hats going
to travel into the yomi
into the underworld let's wait and see
now however the main attraction of this
video this
minor theory was just a warm up now i go
sing this epic song that tells us of the
void century
and the road to love tale well you have
time to hit that subscribe button
and lean back you asked for it you're
getting it
here is o'hara with being sake okay
let's do this
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
uh